-This is very exciting.
I keep forgetting
to mention this,
but the NBA Finals
are going on right now.
I'm a Boston Celtics fan.
My dear friend Andy Samberg
is Golden State Warriors fan.
We made a bet at
the beginning of the Finals,
which is whoever won would write
something about my dog Frisbee
that the other one
would have to read on camera.
The reason this is interesting
and the stakes are high
is that Andy Samberg
hates my dog Frisbee
and often says
that she looks like a rat.
In his defense, that's because
he's a terrible person.
[ Laughter ]
So if you weren't invested
in the NBA Finals, you are now!
The NBA Finals only on NBC.
What was that? Oh, okay.
Well, I shouldn't have said that
then.
[ Laughter ]
ESPN and ABC? Okay.